I don't know if you know this but
Anthony out of our group of boys he's
this ever like he's he's you guys might
be neck and neck in numbers literally a
fallacy right here okay let me ask
if your body count was only the woman
you made how much would it drop
[Music]
so this was kind of like a funny and
dumb poll that I found but it was a
really funny one it says these are the
best cars to have sex in minivan minivan
wow Mazda Miata baby no way dude yeah
right dude it's intimate both your legs
are outside the car when you try to do
that yeah you gotta drop the Top you
gotta stand outside so before we even
get to some of the ones in this article
yeah let's go ahead and talk about our
experiences I used to take my mom's
minivan the one that I uh definitely had
it dinged it up a few times we need year
make model
um it was probably like a 2005 Toyota
minivan but um
dude for sure it's got to be a Sienna it
was big it was big
Previa but they don't exist no more
right no that's old huh is a Toyota oh
this is This SUV the doors closed by
itself uh yeah like on the side but they
go like oh that is a sex van baby yeah
it was so easy is it Toyota sexy yeah
yeah but then I got
I got just taken away because I
um like something about being
compact [__] car space so I hit it
twice and then I got it taken and I have
a Prius because Breeze is still good
it's a lot sex and have you had sex in
that Prius no I haven't too small is it
a lot of space or no no it would just be
really hard on your knees would hurt
it's kind of spacious on the top though
isn't it yeah the little Donuts
you gotta go to the back though the back
seat yeah it's like I just like it when
you can like lay down in a car you know
minivans are the easiest because you
basically have a whole bed that's true
because the seat goes yeah as long as
you don't have the captain shares right
excuse me yeah I thought your phone was
supposed to be on do not disturb it's
supposed to be yeah
I know we all got to check okay wait a
set the example No it should have said
it's an amber alert it's an amber alert
turn those off
why is this Amber Alert here for me only
because because you saved the last kid
so they keep going back to you no I said
last kid
according to the [__] Forbes yeah my
first experience was in a 1996 Toyota
Camry at Griffith Park Observatory
[Music]
yo that'd be hella funny if you look up
and everyone's got the [__] I was
like 20 or something yeah we went on a
date up there
and then uh yeah we're just looking at
stuff and then we got horny because we
were just like making out and touching
each other and [__] and then I was like
oh we gotta pull some of her over and
we're just looking for a place to park
found an empty parking lot and we just
went yeah and we just went to the back
seat when I was so [__] drunk there
was this guy I would always hook up with
in his car because it's like both of our
parents were home a lot and then we
parked at that casino in Inglewood do
you guys know what I'm talking about
yeah
no not that one no there's a that
Crystal Park is it the one that you
could see from the airport when you're
or like when you're flying down
Hollywood Park Hollywood Park Hollywood
Park I was but then so we were [__]
in his back seat get enough I kept
[__] him because it was like I was
drunk and then it was the cop like
shined a flashlight in and then they're
like how old are you and I was like 18.
they're like where's your license I was
like I don't have one he's like so
you're definitely not 18. how old are
you and he's like I'm gonna give you one
last shot and I was like okay I'm 16.
um and the guy who was with because like
I was uh of course I I think I was a
junior and he was a senior so I was 16
turning 17 that year but he was like 18.
he's like oh [__] I'm going to jail I'm
going to jail and um all the cop did was
please get home safe so we went right
back to the party and [__] there and
finished off yeah yeah thank you for not
um I look so innocent I can't do
anything wrong you're at the casino yeah
we were at they probably deal with
crazier [__] there too so they're just
like oh these kids just [__] I
thought but like it was still within the
legal limit like I was a junior he was a
senior like that's not a huge age I got
no no they're probably just like high
school kids [__] yeah yeah you know
the craziest car to I don't even know if
anyone's [__] in a smaller car than
this when I had my DeLorean
is it smaller than a key like what what
is it though smart it's a two-door car
there's no vaccine it's very flat okay
in a smart car it'll be crazy like think
about it this way there's no there's no
parking garage gate that I can't drive
under whoa oh whoa that's crazy when I
had that how did that even work because
there's also a big space in the middle
there's no space anywhere it looks like
this either right it looks like this you
guys busted nuts in there yeah wow the
only way me my homeboy
no it was it was my ex at the time the
only way is is someone's gotta be on
like you got to be on one seat you yeah
right or did you go over like this and
have the stick shift up your butthole
the flux capacitors there dude yeah
that's why we kept stalling but honestly
after enough car sex like you I kind of
got a kink of like please come inside me
because I don't want a mess you know I
was like come inside me yeah
wow because that's what I should have
said right huh I should have said that
yeah no but it was like you're like
sardine so if we go to the passenger
side because it has a little bit more
space yeah without the steering wheel of
course oh dang watch this deal with the
door open oh my God not at a respectable
Macy's
I do have class Anthony
was yours a Miata the Jetta
and it would always like it's still like
anytime I get in a Jetta jetters have a
specific spell I think maybe it was like
the year but it was like makes you super
horny when you smell like you start
rubbing my nibs
I'm like what am I in a Jetta I'm like
What's the 2020 Jetta dude yeah no but
it would smell like [__] crayons like
the AC when the AC would turn on it
would smell like crayon I don't know
what that is crayons but I I met other I
meant other
um like Jedi drivers and they're like
yeah it smells like crayons in there but
to that day anytime I get in that cards
I think of second that's sex I just you
shouldn't think about sex when you smell
crayons dude do you guys like the smell
of gasoline yeah I do I love it Vaseline
gas oh yeah I like gasoline
maybe for adults too okay Joe no they
can't I tried it as soon as I said it I
was like all right did you guys try to
smell Sharpies when you're [__] I got a
drug test to pass no whoa what does that
do nothing but people talked about it
all the time what does that do oh it's
supposed to make you high somehow but
I'm like
how are you gonna pass a drug test by
having Sharpie inhalation well because
they can still get high yeah like you
can still get high without
okay you guys know I just looked at it
and I was like this isn't gonna get me
high yeah I need something crazy
[Laughter]
that's true because when you've done
real [__] when you take like Vicodin and
stuff it's just I just feel like
like I'm just chilling yeah yeah and
it's smoking cigarettes and all that
stuff it's like um what am I doing it
for it doesn't feel like anything yeah
yeah it's like you Skydive and then
they're like oh you guys want to jump
off the curb all right what
um did you ever have sex in a truck bed
no I had a uh so when I was in high
school I had a a Honda CRV but the green
ones that all the Asian moms have that
is Tiny this car that's perfect it's
like a 2000 so the back was tight it
would fold it down and that was like our
Rave mobile yeah yeah yeah people could
either you could actually trunk it
comfortably too oh CRV I was thinking
CRX total different experience CRV so we
would pack the car and then we could
even sit three other people in the trunk
if we were going to a rave or whatever
so that was tight that was pretty cool
what about you Anthony Lee you've been
real silent yeah yeah what kind of car
were you [__] in yeah yeah I thought
you would be the biggest car [__] here
yeah is there a car you haven't yeah
guys I don't have a lot of cars like
what do you I don't know if you noticed
but Anthony out of our group of boys
he's the sex Tapper like he's he's the
you guys might be neck and neck in
numbers literally a fallacy right here
okay let me ask you a question if your
body count was only the woman you made
come how much would it drop
was only the woman I made
drop Anthony or would it race
okay or what just what would your body
count be if it was only the woman you
made come I don't even know if I would
answer my body count on this anyway
the girls that you may come though is it
pretty low yeah it's definitely super
low super low absolutely
um you're humble you're a Gemini I'm a
Gemini when's your birthday June 4th
minus six nine really yeah 69 which I
don't even like that move but it's
fitting I like Nintendo 64.
I don't even like that Nintendo 64. so
as we continue in the subject we'll jump
off of me
this is a Honda Element yeah yo elements
are really spacious that's David so's
car dude yeah wait dude you can just run
it you can run a jiu jitsu Dojo out of
that [__] you get some rolls out of
there
so you gotta you gotta think about what
you can do out there you know if you go
if you got an infatuation for getting it
down you could teach class in there man
yo my Land Cruiser is pretty nice for
[__] everybody have you had sex with
it no we had uh we mutually masturbated
each other because we were tired yeah I
got tired that's tight wow so this is a
vector W8 Ryan you familiar with the
vector wa yeah hell yeah I know the guy
who [__] created that [__] so
obviously when you see there's no middle
console for you know any of the extras
then uh there's a lot a lot of room to
work with oh that's like my truck right
now so are you all car guys I'm assuming
he's a very good car guy he likes cars
very much as well he's got cars in
general me and Nick not really what do
you think about my Prius
that's a very good choice I'm a fan of
the Prius I like it it's a
it's a good it's a great choice I I like
medic I like three weeks ago and he's
like you make how much and you're still
driving a Prius yeah well that's why you
can keep more money yeah yeah I'm a like
like I mean I I can't spend dumb like my
money on dumb [__] like a lot of food or
something but like you need to eat it's
not like I'm spending it on I don't know
I actually think that's smarter and
better and more attractive especially
because if a girl was like trying to
constantly get validation and buying
[__] that she doesn't even care about
just to feel like she needs to like
floss then I think that's pretty
unattractive but if you're just like I'm
not even into cars this thing is clean
it takes me from this point at this
point I'm like that's great especially
in La where people drive like [__]
why do you need to get a Lamborghini
there's there's no problem with you
having a Prius but if you had a RAV4
Prime I would be more attracted that's a
good cause you know what I'm saying
though
if I was like making if maybe not cardi
B money but if I was making like
I don't know Kazumi money like she you
know she's [__] stacked like I would
maybe want like a pink Tesla or
something but it's like I don't want to
do that till like I have a lot of wiggle
room and I won't have to like worry
about it worry about it the guy that
spoke he exposed his cards and he's more
of a look rich than rather be rich
person I'm like oh you're a loser I'd
rather be rich than look rich because I
feel like my parents always like like my
dad is like look at my Ferrari and my
small cockline
yeah awesome
also real car guys completely know that
they're spending money on something
stupid right but they love it but it's
like but if you're getting on someone
else's [__] then it's like you're not a
car guy you're a [__] money guy yeah
have you had your catalytic converter
stolen yet have I had what your
catalytic converter stolen what's up
it's a it's a piece of uh piece of part
of the exhaust yeah they get stolen on
Priuses a lot it gets jacked up please
all the people I know at Priuses have
gotten their [__] stolen at least once
yeah I surprisingly have never I even am
stupid sometimes and don't um lock my
car still nothing
I've been pretty lucky I've never had a
phone stolen knock on yeah that's good
yeah somewhere in there
but yeah pretty but I'm also like pretty
I don't know well you live in a nicer
area too so it's probably not gonna
happen yeah like even in Tucson though
when I was at in college I didn't get
[__] stolen wow yeah good for you I did
step on glass though
what the [__]
foreign
[Music]